in the third installment
of burger scholar sessions one man
sets out to cook 10 mind-blowing
regional hamburgers
and that man's me it's gonna be good
smell that is your real time tested
regional favorites from around the
country look at that
this burger is a deep fried bird
anything could happen
oh [ __ ] you see that there's more
burgers to be had
and way more history to uncover
let's make a ramen burger [ __ ] that's
delicious
hola amigos there's so many different
recipes for fermented cheese
one of my personal favorites is from my
mom let's call her
[Music]
hey georgie how'd you know it's me
your face shows up on my screen oh
we're gonna make the perfect steakhouse
style burger
right here let's go for a ride we're
going through
regional american fast food burger
history
oh wow
what burger scholar sessions season
three with me
george boats hey my name is george moats
don't forget to like and subscribe to
first we feast and get more episodes of
burger scholar
right here
where